he's Peter Billingsley actor director
producer executive producer of
undeniable with Dan Patrick so obviously
he's used to working with great talent
ATT original on DirecTV the audience and
producer Iron Man he's done a lot of
different things longtime actor good
friends with Vince Vaughn and of course
Ralphie from A Christmas Story and Peter
who just loves talking about Ralphie
from A Christmas Story I'm gonna guess
right Pete absolutely good morning Dan
how often do you hear something about a
Christmas Story I hear it multiple times
a year especially around this time it's
crazy it's like the movie that you know
when it came out not to a lot of fanfare
was sort of a medium hit and then kind
of went away and this was back in 83 and
I think because of the boom of cable and
video it just started growing every year
and then started working its way up
these lists of all-time favorites and
then got him top fives and it still
seems as relevant today as it did this
do you remember the premiere did you go
to a premiere yeah well it was more kind
of regional back then so it didn't have
the kind of big Hollywood fanfare that
it did but I just the Academy of Motion
Pictures just did a screening it's the
35th anniversary and I just saw it in a
theater it's like 700 people on a
35-millimeter print and it was awesome
and you got to see it with a crowd and
here we're all the laughs were and it
gave me a newfound appreciation for the
movie if I would have told you 35 years
ago hey you know what they're gonna be
playing that forever it'll be one of the
more popular movies Christmas movies of
all time what would you say no way in
hell would that happen this was an
awesome movie it took them 12 years to
get it made oh well it was based on and
I'm on an anthology of short stories Bob
Clarke who directed the movie took him
12 years he had done some horror films
in fact the first day that I got there
he was excited he said oh I just
finished my last film I'm doing a screen
tonight would love you to come see it
what to watch it it was Porky's too
not exactly family fair that would
catapult this film to greatness but it
was a really interesting example Dan it
was like I sort of describe it as the
lunch pail movie like people just taking
their lunch pail to work and working
hard I've been on a lot of big-budget
movies that did not do well where there
was all the hype and now kid this is
going to make you a star in this one
like they were so well prepared and they
just got it and it was a refreshing
experience it was challenging we shot it
in Cleveland and in Canada we shot in a
cold and the winter in January outside
but it was a very different experience
than I had ever had and it was probably
a pretty good lesson learned early for
me did you save anything from that movie
well my mom always kept memorabilia from
all the things I did with no hope that
you know they would have any value or
anything but I actually have the bunny
suit I have the cowboy outfit and I have
the original gun this is crazy that's
great you see you got the red rifle BB
gun yeah and I have the pink suit Oh
what do you think that gun is real good
what do you think that guns were I don't
know I mean it's kept in a
humidity-controlled safe I can say yeah
the the bunny outfit yeah it looks
painful like you played the role
brilliantly are you really in pain are
you like just sad like you're you're any
kind of masculinity is taken away from
you even at that age I would worry at
the time not a lot of acting required in
that element for sure embarrassing on
the set I'll tell you the worst thing I
was a scene that was cut out of the
movie
there was another fantasy sequence that
was a big space deal we were up on the
lake up on the moon and Flash Gordon was
pinned down by Ming the Merciless and I
got the call Ralphie did to come save
him in my own mind of course and I show
up there and the Wardrobe lady had
designed these keen shiny
silver like panties for me to wear and I
was outraged and so self-conscious and
probably my performance in that scene is
why it's not in the movie
how old were you at the time 12 oh okay
so right on the wall looking and playing
younger yeah well you did well and we
were wondering what we would want out of
that where's the pole that that's like
put his tongue on didn't anybody ever
take that no that was just you know what
it was it was basically the way you
would have designed it in your mind if
you were forced to do it it was like uh
it wasn't metal it was sort of a piece
of plastic and I had a teeny tiny hole
that sucked air and the camera was just
at an angle you couldn't see it hold on
this is news this is breaking news we've
been wondering for years now movie magic
special effects yeah yeah what was your
favorite story from that move from the
movie set I think probably just in many
ways how much fun we had you know it was
we shot it in January Cleveland kept the
decorations up in downtown so it was
sort of a continuation of Christmas and
that the slide which they had and a big
Santa sequence they were in that Higby
store for a couple of days and when they
would call lunch none of us would eat
the kids we would just go down that same
forward backwards just keep going like
that to make up let's go we just didn't
want to get off but it was an awful lot
of fun and a tremendous experience was
Nicholson up to play your dad we said
yeah that's what Bob that's what Bob had
said I think Bob Clark the director had
said that he I think was his first
choice and it talked to Jack about doing
it but you know it's hard to not see
Darrin in that role now and Darrin did
such an amazing job now I can't see Jack
like Jack would have been too big for
the role I think yeah or two I mean I
guess but you know this dad was kind of
scary too that's one of the things I
think that one of the reasons it sort of
doers of timelessness you know the movie
that takes place probably 1940 but it
feels relevant today because it's a it's
a very real family you know it is sort
of a tough dad it's a very loving mom
you know there's there's a lot of love
in that household there's not a lot of
money they're working hard they're
struggling there's a lot of hopes and
dreams but I think at the end of the day
there is there is a lot of love there
and that's definitely what he got right
when's the last time you were flipping
through the channels and all of a sudden
there you are and then what do you do in
that movie yeah if it winds up at our
house Christmas as well it's just we
kind of put on the background I don't
personally but somebody in the house
winds up putting it on and flipping
through young though they don't really
know who Ralphie is do they not yet no I
think it's gonna be an awakening for
them now
but I'm gonna let them find it on their
own you know slowly but it for some
reason it's sort of become a tradition
we have a big family and you know go see
my parents and lots of nieces and
nephews and it didn't bear ibly winds up
on the house which is sort of a fun
thing so now what almost doesn't feel
like Christmas if it's not on but how
aware are you of your movie a more
challenging I don't know I don't really
think about it that way you know it's
maybe it's different when you're in it a
lot of people have said a lot of people
I think that I know that had sort of an
iconic role sometimes try to run from it
or don't wanna talk about it you know I
don't do obviously a lot of press was
excited to come share it with you
because you know we're working together
and so forth but but it brings a lot of
people a lot of joy and so that's all
you know why would you want to run from
that you know and people are very
genuine when they when they approach me
and say hi so you know it's it's a great
film it's something that people like and
so I certainly don't mind talking about
it do you get royalties no you know
that's sort of the bummer
maybe that's why the in my perspective
is [ __ ] it's like you gotta find the joy
in it exactly not financial there be far
more joy intial yeah yes you would take
them finding the silver lining you take
the leg lamp royalties I think
absolutely no my gosh I need to think
that there's merchandising off this
movie which is nuts you know you would
not think for this little kind of
character comedy about a kid that wants
a BB gun
we there would actually be this sort of
stuff from it Peter and I have been
working together on undeniable it's the
interview show that Joe Buck did for
years and Peter's the brains behind it
and you know you have a directors eye
like you produce but you have a
directors eye and then I know that
you've done producing and directing
Ironman some I mean you've you've been
involved in a lot of other things but I
appreciate your eye behind the camera
when I'm doing these interviews and I
did the full disclosure Tony Stewart is
one of our guests and Tony we were
trying to get him to lighten up and
relax and have a little bit of fun and
and he wasn't and so I said Peter came
over to say hello to Tony and I go uh
and then Peter laughs then I go up you
know he's Ralphie and a Christmas Story
Antonio's are you kidding me like his
mood changed I said yeah he goes are you
serious I said yeah that's that's
Ralphie and he goes I got to get a
picture there so I didn't use it but you
know I I wasn't planning it whenever you
want it is yours I trust you with it the
best guests that we have on undeniable
the interview start in January so your
favorite interview the ten that we did
is who was first and you did a great job
and I think your fans are gonna love
seeing this and we are excited to bring
this back probably my favorite guest was
great was Greg Norman this year that
surprises me not that he wasn't a great
interview
I just I thought that you had other
guests that maybe were you know Cheryl
Miller was emotional Ray Lewis Ray Lewis
told the story of a story yep yeah he
story about that night in Atlanta like
you know he Freddie Roach has a story
but you know I'm not and I'm not gonna
give away but is an absolute must watch
for audiences this seemingly sweet
mild-mannered man who is so talented
yeah has quite a pass but I'll tell you
about Greg you know one of the great
things about the show my business
partner has been spawn and this was his
idea for this show is that you get this
sort of an incredible emotional journey
of these athletes but you can also
extract a lot of life advice along the
way and these are guys who have
succeeded at the top of the game and
Greg Norman has gone on to be with such
a great golfer but it's such an
incredible businessman seemingly
everything he gets involved with is
incredibly successful and so I found a
lot of his approaches inspiring you know
and things there was one that his old
coach had said do it now do it proper
dinner dip it's something that stays
with me so I find sometimes in just in
working on these and then being able to
watch the cuts as a fan that I can draw
a lot from them and there's a moment
where I'm showing all this heartbreak
with Greg Norman and just it's just it
felt like and here's another clip where
you lose in dramatic fashion and here's
one more Greg and then I caught myself
at one point I just said and I can't do
it I can't do it he goes show it show it
and I go okay here here's Greg losing
and heartbreaking fashion again but he
he stood in with every one of and that's
the thing you know there's sensitive
topics obviously with Ray Lewis we had
not heard what I thought was his
opportunity in full to explain what
happened spending time in jail like his
careers in doubt and he said I
appreciate you letting me have the time
to tell my story and he did I thought
Tony Stewart on the night that a fellow
driver was was killed on a short
he told his story he told us and I you
know that's where it's powerful you're
exactly right you know even it's one of
the things I think that is sometimes
missing some sports culture is the long
form the truly long form you know
there's just a mandate to get so much
into a short period of time where it's
just a post press conference or it's a
post game sound bright locker room this
show allows them the platform to give a
10 or 12 minute answer and we will put
that on television because it's a chance
for them to create the narrative and for
them to frame it so I think they
appreciate it they appreciate the
opportunity as much as we enjoy doing it
it's well done and I look forward to
rolling out the season six of undeniable
being January I believe Ray Lewis is the
first interview that we have that's
exactly right we will be announcing the
date shortly but it's coming up in
January with Ray and we have a lot of
great episodes coming up and again Dan
you did a great job could you bring the
BB gun the next time we're in Los
Angeles we're just down to set quietly
and show you yeah - yeah just come on
the set and and we could you bring open
the box we take a peek yeah but you know
like could you bring some of the
memorabilia for a Christmas story we I
won't we won't touch I can bring the gun
down for you yes because that's easily
to transport okay by the way if you want
me to put out this entire clip of all
the questions of a Christmas story and
then just say you know what Peter is not
going to answer any more questions for
four references for a Christmas story
just go to this we just turned we just
turned to the Dan Patrick so yeah and I
think we've pretty much covered at home
I'll be in touch Peter thank you for
being a good scene thank you buddy all
right Peter Billingsley actor director
producer and I'm working with him on
undeniable for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]